(electronic music)
- Good afternoon, everybody.
Happy Tuesday.
Today's one of those days in
which our biweekly lecture
is going to be delivered by a guest.
And our guest lecturer
is Professor Arne Westad.
Arne Westad studied history, philosophy,
and modern languages at
the University of Oslo
before doing a graduate degree in U.S.
and international history
at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill.
Before joining the faculty at Yale,
where he is the Elihu
Professor of History,
he held positions at the
London School of Economics
and Harvard University.
Professor Westad has published 16 books,
most of which deal with 20th century
Asian and global history.
He is one of the world's leading
historians of the Cold War,
which he worked on for a
significant part of his career,
writing important work
about the Soviet Bloc
and the People's Republic of China.
He now specializes in the histories
of empire and imperialism,
as well as China's place
in the international order.
Today, in one of our very
last meetings of this course,
he will deliver a lecture
about comparative Russian imperialism.
Arne, the floor is yours.
- Thank you.
(students applauding)
Thank you, Wiktor, for
that generous introduction.
I can see the Russian empire
up here flicking off and on,
and that's a little bit
like what the Russian Empire
has been over a long period of time.
So maybe that's illustrative
of what we are going to talk about today.
So I think the reason why I've
been asked to do this lecture
is that I teach a class
this semester here at Yale
on comparative empires and imperialisms.
So where we look at the
transformations of empires
going back to the mid-19th century
and all the way up to
the U.S. empire today.
It's an undergraduate seminar,
and I hope the undergraduates enjoy it
half as much as what I do.
So the purpose of the lecture
is trying to understand better
how Russian imperialism
versus Ukraine today
fits into a bigger context.
So both of Russia's own past as an empire,
but also that of the other empires.
And I think one of the
problems that we've had
conceptually and interpretatively
with regard to Russia's
war of aggression this year
is that it hasn't been understood enough
in terms of those contexts.
And I hope this class overall
have helped the people
who are here or those who are watching
understand that aspect
of the conflict better,
because it is, to me, crucial,
not just in terms of
the conduct of the war,
but also how the war is going to end.
Without understanding
that deeper background,
it's really hard to
get to understand that.
So I'm gonna be looking, as
I said, at Russia's own past,
but also gonna be looking,
although briefly, at China,
at France, at Britain, and to
some extent, to United States,
which also I think in terms of its past
certainly best should be
understood as an empire.
And I'm gonna start with the
drivers of Russian imperialism
coming out of the 19th century
that stayed with us for a very long time.
And you will hear
resonances of these today.
I'm going to talk about the competition
between the Russian Empire
and other empires in Europe
and outside of Europe.
I'm going to talk in particular
about the Qing Empire in China,
the Ottoman Empire in the Middle East
and Eastern Europe and Britain.
Just to get a sense of how
this element of competition
came to frame much of the thinking
both back in the early 20th century,
but also today about
Russia's place in the world.
Then I'm going to do
in the substantial part
more of a direct comparison between Russia
and its relationship
to Ukraine and Britain,
really meaning England, in
its relationship to Ireland,
and France in its relationship to Algeria.
And I picked these up not
because they're identical,
they're not identical,
but they have a lot in common
in terms of how long the
involvement has lasted.
But also crucially, to me,
that this is a matter of decolonization.
Even though these areas,
these countries are close
to the Imperial Centers,
Ireland and Algeria,
their evolution has been an evolution
driven in the 20th
century by decolonization.
And what I'm indicating here, of course,
is that the relationship
between Russia and Ukraine
is in many ways similar in character,
not in every context
of those relationships.
And then I'm gonna finish
before we hopefully have time
for just a couple of questions
about talking about what drives
Russian imperialism today,
especially, but not exclusively,
with regard to Ukraine.
So that's the overall
framework for this lecture.
And some of this of course
you will have touched upon before,
but probably not in the context
that we're trying to draw up today.
So let me start then
with the drivers of Russian imperialism.
Is there anyone who can stop that map
from flicking on and off?
- [Speaker] Press Escape
button on the keyboard.
No, no, no, keyboard ESC.
- Press the Escape button.
- [Speaker] Yeah.
- That seems to be a good idea.
So we're gonna start by thinking
about the drivers of Russian imperialism,
the way that it came
out of the 19th century.
Some of these drivers, in my view,
as you will hear later on in the lecture,
have stayed relatively intact
and others have changed.
The argument I'm putting forward here
is not an argument about
absolute continuity.
It is about the need to understand
the starting point for many
of these forms of thinking.
Without which, I think we
are lost in our attempt
at understanding what
is the situation today.
(telephone ringing)
It's this one.
It's not me.
(students laughing)
(telephone ringing)
Probably.
It should have been a red phone, right?
So the first of these drivers
is also the most complex one.
It's a sense on the Russian side
within the Russian elite
or elites of uniqueness,
of exceptionalism, of standing apart
as an empire from other empires.
Now, Russia, you underline this,
Russia is not the only empire
that thinks of itself in that way.
You are sitting here within an empire
that thinks of itself very
much in that way, right?
What is a little bit special with Russia
is how comprehensively some
of these ideas developed
from fairly early on about religion,
about authenticity, which is
a term that is often used,
for Russian speakers
here, "samoefikasnost"
which can be translated
in many different ways,
but self being, very often,
and I think most correctly,
certainly in the context
of the 19th century,
translated as at authenticity,
being close to the people,
having a certain almost mystical
connection between elites.
Then of course being imperial elites,
and the vast majority of people
who were included in the empire,
not just Russians, it should be said,
but everyone that was
included within the empire.
A genuine understanding of people's wishes
that other empires,
according to these texts,
did not possess.
A search for a genuine order
that could represent those
wishes of the people.
Of course leading to the idea
or the ideal of benign authoritarian rule.
And you will hear much
of this being reflected
in some of the discourses
later on as well.
And speaking of this, by the way,
I'm reminded of the
great British historian,
Sir Lewis Namier.
I don't know if Namier's name has come up
earlier in this series of lectures.
He was one of the people,
though most of his work
was on British constitutional history,
who gave voice to this idea
about a particular link
between Russia, Russian
empire, and authenticity.
So Namier was born in Warsaw
in the late 19th century
under the name of Bernstein.
He then moved with his family
to Ternopil, where he grew up.
Polefied, is that the word?
Polefying his name to Niemirowski,
which then became Namier
when he came to Britain as a student.
Authenticity was the
term that he often used.
He hated the Polish Republic.
He hated Germany even more.
He was ambivalent on Ukraine,
but he was big on Russia
because it was authentic, right?
In a way that other empires,
including the British Empire,
which he served for most
of his life, were not.
So this is the first driver:
uniqueness, exceptionalism, authenticity.
The second one, it seems to me,
is the emphasis within
the official discourse
of expansion as being defensive.
Now, again, other empires do this as well.
There is always a border
that needs to be pacified.
We're gonna talk about
the Qing Empire later on,
always a border to be pacified,
the British Empire stumbled
into its empire, et cetera.
But it's never emphasized
as deeply and for as long,
in my view, as the expansion
of the Russian Empire.
And much of it was then rubbed off
in a somewhat different
form to the Soviet Union,
when that was reconstituted later on
within what had been the Russian Empire.
Now, some of this is easy to understand,
the emphasis on defense.
Part of the reason is
that Russia, of course,
confronted empires east and west,
that for most of its existence,
were much stronger than Russia itself.
In Europe, for sure,
but also the Ottomans,
and certainly the Qing in East Asia,
as the Russian empire
discovered fairly early
in its expansion East, you
didn't mess with the Qing.
That was not a good idea.
It was probably in terms of
sheer military capability
combined with a ideology of aggression,
the one that you really didn't
want to come up against.
So this idea of expansion
as being defensive
in order to meet challenges
that other empires are stronger,
very significant in the 19th century.
Then thirdly, expansion as opportunistic.
And this is the one
that is most problematic
in a way to deal with,
because it isn't 100% true.
I mean, it's not arguing
that there weren't plans
for expansion within the Russian
Empire in the 19th century.
There certainly were such plans,
but in a way, I would argue
that were much less carried through on
in the Russian Empire than in
any other empire that I know,
including the ones that
I mentioned so far.
Part of the explanation
for that is, of course,
the relative weakness that
I have already referred to.
But then of course, making use
from the mid-19th century on
of a unique moment when the Eastern,
and here I would include
Britain, meaning British India,
the eastern empires that Russia
confronted got into trouble,
all three of them, the Qing,
the British, and the Ottomans,
roughly at the same time.
The Qing, mainly for domestic
reasons, I would argue,
and then followed by what confrontations
with Western imperialism,
the Ottomans because of the
beginning of nationalist
organizations in part
of the Ottoman Empire,
especially in the European
part, and the British,
because of the rebellion
in India in the 1850s.
So instead of pushing outwards,
these empires start to step aside,
opening up for a remarkable period
of Russian imperial expansion.
Now, that's opportunistic.
It's opportunistic for a reason.
That reason is the weakness of others.
But it also tells you something
about the ability to act.
And that is what happened
in the late 19th century.
And the result you see up here,
in terms of this is the Russian Empire,
and on 1914 or thereabouts.
If you look at the red line,
which is the one that
we are really broke upon
massive expansion of territory.
Then fourthly, a driver
of Russian imperialism
coming out of the 19th century
is the emphasis on hierarchy,
bureaucracy incorporation of elites.
Also, meaning, it was non-Russian elites.
So again, these are characteristics
you would find in any empire,
but particularly, the
emphasis on the incorporation
is something that the
Russian Empire took very far.
Most of the people, I think
Putin will be profoundly shocked
if he reflects on this,
but most of the people who constituted
the expansionist elite
in the Russian empire were not Russian.
They came out of other, mainly European,
not exclusively, peoples that were part
of the Russian empire in the 19th century.
They staffed and mandated,
and they were the bureaucrats
that came to serve it,
which was part in a way of the promise
that the empire presented to them
in terms of how working for
and with the Russian Empire
could serve a lot of people
who were not necessarily Russian,
or perhaps even more crucially,
had not been born in a
dominion of the Tsar.
That worked.
And it worked for a very, very long time.
It wasn't uncontroversial.
Certainly not in the areas
that had been colonized.
Neither was it uncontroversial
within Russia itself,
but it was a powerful aspect
of how the Russian empire worked.
People who were born, grew
up in Ukraine, for instance,
in many cases, went to
serve the Russian Empire
in far away places, Poles,
Germans, Belarusians,
you have it.
I won't go through all
the different groups
that served in these kinds of worlds.
So hierarchy, bureaucracy, incorporation.
Of course, a driver of
Russian expansionism
was also the exploitation of resources.
So for those who were already thinking,
"Aha, here's Professor Westad arguing
a completely idealistic understanding
of Russian imperialism."
Not so.
I mean, there were
motives that were driven
by the wish for exploitation of resources
outside what had been the
established borders of the empire.
What is remarkable though
about the Russian Empire
for a very, very long time
was that it was relatively ineffective
in exploiting those resources.
So this was not for a lack of trying,
but if you look at this map,
and you will have heard this many times,
I'm sure, in this class,
distance sometimes defeated
the best purpose of exploitation, right?
You could grab the resources,
as all imperialists do,
that you want and that you need,
but could you easily bring them to market,
which here would be mainly in the West?
Did you even necessarily
want to bring them to market
when you could use them
to strengthen the state
much more locally?
Those are questions that need to be asked
about the Russian empire.
So saying that this is
not about the exploitation
of resources as almost
all imperial ventures are,
would be wrong, but it's
also important to remember
her relatively ineffective,
inefficient for a very long time
the Russian Empire's exploitation
of these resources were.
And then the final driver
that I'm going to mention,
there are many, but it
has to stop somewhat.
It's about settlement.
So again, if you look at the map,
we should have had a map that indicated
where people from various parts of Russia
settled during the empire,
but especially after
emancipation, from the 1860s,
you have a massive expansion of settlement
in various parts of Russia, far
from where people were born.
So not just saying that it
was (indistinct) who settled.
They were fairly large number,
but there were also
other kinds of peoples.
The empire, in a way,
opened up for settlement.
For those of you who are here
primarily because of your
interest in Ukrainian history,
you should look at where
Ukrainians have ended up
all over the Russian empire.
Maybe especially look at the far east
and what is today the Maritime provinces,
which has a very large number
of people from Ukraine settling.
This is important, because
not all empires settle, right?
There are some,
Russia is among them, where settlement,
trend settlement, whatever
you want to call it,
is an important part of the drivers.
We're gonna come back to
this a little bit later on.
And there are others that
are too much less of it.
And then of course
there other hybrid ones,
like the British Empire that
would settle in some areas,
which is part why fairly large
number of you are here today.
North America would settle,
Australia would settle parts of Africa,
and carrying out at least episodic
acts of genocide as they did so.
But then in other parts
of the British Empire,
settlement was not on the agenda.
There was very little
British settlement in India,
for instance.
And we can, if you are interested
in comparative imperial history,
we could move further
into why that was so.
I often use the example of Korea.
So Korea was in some kind of
union in a very broad sense,
being linked to Chinese empires
for a very, very long time.
But there were no Chinese attempts
at settling Chinese people in
Korea during that time period.
From the early 20th century,
Korea became gradually a
part of the Japanese empire,
and the Japanese settled
in very large numbers.
So it's important,
particularly for those of you
who have an interest in concepts
linked to certain colonialism,
it's important to understand
what this is really about,
and what the forces are, the drivers of it
why it consult the way it is.
So these are the drivers
of Russian imperialism
at the higher level the way I see them.
So let's then turn to
the issue of competition
that I mentioned originally.
And I do think that this is
important in order to understand
why we ended up with a Russian empire
that control all of
this enormous land mass
that we are looking at here.
And you will know this, and
I'm not gonna dwell on it,
Russian expansion towards the
east and towards the south
and into other parts of
Europe started quite early.
We're talking about the 17th century,
in the early 17th century.
But of course, during that
time period, as I already said,
the Russian Empire had to be very careful
not to come up against stronger empires,
which would basically
whack them if they tried
to get into the areas that were contested.
So most of that expansion
went northward and eastward
into areas in which the
anti-imperial resistance
were much weaker.
That was the story for
a very, very long time.
And it's really the 19th
century that changes this.
As I already indicated,
it's important sometimes to
recognize this in history.
The Russian Empire, in
many ways, got lucky.
It got lucky with the Qing.
It got lucky with the Ottomans.
It got lucky with the
British for no reason
connected to the Russian
Empire itself, right?
There was the opportunity to
expand into enormous areas,
because of that weakness
of Russia's opponents.
So you see that here along the
borders of the Russian Empire
going into the (indistinct),
going into Central Asia,
Southern parts of Central Asia,
which had been an absolute no-no,
because if you went in there,
you got in trouble with the Qing.
And then of course,
ultimately, in the far east,
what became the Maritime
provinces were taken directly
from the Qing Empire when the Qing
got into real trouble in
the late 19th century.
I think we can learn a lot
about how empires behave
if we think about them in
terms of competition, right?
Not just each empire for itself,
which generally has been the approach,
but also how empires
learn from each other,
how they see each other.
My Princeton colleague Jeremy Adelman
has written really well on this.
I mean, how empires take
over characteristics,
take over imperial
technologies from others.
And in many ways, this is what Russia
then proceeded to do in the 19th century.
Of course, not just in the
areas that were taken over,
but in other parts of the
Russian Empire as well.
This sudden explosion in
expansion also gave rise
to much of this restlessness
that took place in other parts of Russia,
which even truly would lead
up to the fatal engagement
in the war in 1914, and
then to the collapse
of the Russian Empire in the revolution.
A collapse that quite a number
of historians will explain,
at least in part, by overstretch,
that they were trying
to do too many things
at the same time and therefore failed.
There's a lot to be said for that.
Yale colleague Paul Kennedy's term
"imperial overstretch" I think
is incredibly well applied
to Russia in the late 19th century.
So comparison is not just a
issue by issue comparison,
at least to me.
Comparison can also tell us a great deal
when you think about it
in a broader context,
in a societal context,
an economic context, and
maybe first and foremost,
in a state context.
Not just about political systems,
but about how one create
or tries to create
capable states that respond to these kinds
of imperialist opportunities
as they come out.
Now, I thought at this point,
that it could be quite
helpful for us to explore
some of the categories that most of which
we have already touched upon
in terms of drawing a
more immediate comparison,
as I said, to begin with,
between Russia, Britain, and France.
I'm not picking these three
because they are the only three
that you could possibly compare.
I mentioned the Qing.
I mentioned the United States,
but there is something in particular
about the start of expansion
with these empires,
Russia, Britain, France,
that I think can be quite illustrative.
And many people now lost decade or so
who want to work on comparative
empires and imperialisms,
have started looking at these factors.
With Ukraine being a
significant part of it
in terms of its relationship to Russia.
And the parallels then,
as I said, to begin with,
is the English in Ireland
and the French in Algeria,
both early attempts at colonization
that lasted for a very long
time and ultimately failed.
They failed because the people
who lived in these regions
took on identities, accepted identities,
worked through identities
that were not commensurate
with imperial project
that had been put on them
from the outside, even
though significant elements,
think language remained,
or after that imperial period was over.
Anti-colonial revolutionaries in Algeria
mainly wrote in French.
The activist of the Sinn Féin
and the Irish Republican Army
used almost exclusively English.
So there are things that do remain.
But let's look at this in terms of
some more specific comparisons.
One, and here we get to
go back to that term again
is of course about settlement.
This is difficult
because settlement happen
in slightly different forms
in these three countries.
So in Algeria, in Ireland, and in Ukraine.
So in Ireland settlement,
English settlement,
happened more or less
all over the country.
But then increasingly,
and here we see a parallel to Ukraine,
increasingly, as industrialism
started to take hold
in the most resource rich,
energy rich parts of the country,
meaning the north, right?
And the parallel here,
of course, is Donbas
in the eastern parts of
Ukraine in particular.
There's also a parallel to France
in Algeria, where it
was the most productive,
but mainly in agricultural terms,
areas along the coast that were colonized
by French-speaking people,
not necessarily people
who came from France,
but people whose main language was French
and moved into these areas
under the auspices of the French Empire.
In all three of these countries,
in terms of settlement activities,
the native population
were mainly excluded.
Not fully excluded, but mainly excluded.
The arguments that were being used
for this were of different kinds.
One had to do with education
and skills, which of course,
the empire that was in
control deliberately deprived
the people they were ruling over of.
If you ever heard of a
self-fulfilling prophecy,
you can see that that one is there.
But also, of course, loyalty
to the imperial project,
which was very, very significant
probably as we already touched upon,
in all three of these cases,
particularly in the late 19th century,
settlement was a part of expanding
one's own population overseas.
And in these cases, of course,
in areas that were pretty close
to the imperial model country,
which is important in this context.
But the comparisons here are
not just about settlement.
They're also about incorporation.
And this is when things I
think get really interesting.
The idea at the Imperial
Center of these countries,
which had, for most of the countries,
had a separate existence
being an integral part
of the imperial homeland,
not just the imperial state.
Imperial states are vast,
over to the peripheries.
And no would, or very few people,
especially if you're not French,
would make an argument
that these faraway places
actually are a part of France
or part of whatever, right?
But if you happen to be next door,
it is more problematic in many ways.
So you get this argument
in the late 19th century,
which has resonated all the way
down to very close to today,
that Ireland really belongs to Britain.
It is part of the British Isles, right?
It should be incorporated.
More incorporation is what is necessary,
not less incorporation.
Until, of course, the British hit
at one of the weaker moments in history,
an armed rebellion that
they couldn't overcome,
that established an Irish state.
But in the process of that,
this is where incorporation
really resonates.
The British kept hold of the north,
of the northern parts of Ireland,
which had been the part
that had been mostly settled
by English people, Scottish people,
other people from the
empire who had come in
to work at the factories
and work in the areas,
in the north.
In the Franco-Algerian situation,
things were even worse in
terms of finding a solution,
because as many of you will know,
in the late 1940s and 1950s,
the position that the French state took
was that Algeria was an
integral part of France.
Even considering any form of autonomy,
nevermind independence for Algeria
was tantamount to devaluing
the whole significance
and position of the French state,
which is why that War of Independence
became so incredibly vicious, right?
Because it had to do with identity,
and identity both within
the former colonized area
and within the imperial center.
Exploitation is an important part of this,
and various kinds of
exploitation of near areas
in terms of empire.
I think there are some parallels here
as well with regard to these three.
When I say exploitation, I'm
not always thinking about it
in sort of purely material terms,
though that is a significant part of it,
as I have already described.
But it goes further than that.
It's also making use of
the manpower, for instance,
for wars, for further wars of expansion.
If you look at the number
of Algerians that served
in France's wars during the
20th century, especially,
it's a very, very large number.
The number of Irish people who served
in various British armies,
sometimes as the front troops for this,
are also very, very high, right?
So it's not just about
economic exploitation,
it's also exploitation of the manpower
that is actually there.
It's also other forms of exploitation.
Sexual exploitation is one part
of this in a gendered sense,
which I think is really
important to emphasize.
Its exploitation in terms of
when you have more development
as you did during the mid-20th century.
Exploitation of resources in terms of
everything from currency to fuel.
When you think about
imperialist exploitation
in these near contexts,
you sort of have to take the
smash and grab version, right?
Of exploitation that most of us think of
in imperialist terms and magnify it,
look at it through a
slightly different lens,
in part because the cases
that I'm talking about here
were not cases of resources
having to be brought in from afar.
They were pretty close
and easily accessible.
So settlement,
incorporation, exploitation.
And then finally, cultural hegemony.
I'm gonna dwell on this a little bit
because I think it is hugely important
for all three of these cases.
So I talked about language
to begin with in this part,
and how language had been
used in order to incorporate
certainly elites, but after a while,
to further a field as well
into the imperial project.
Ukraine is of course the best example
that I know of this, right?
But Ireland and Algeria
would not be far behind.
Prioritizing the culture
of the colonizer is,
as Edward Said and others have told us,
a really important aspect of continuing
the imperial tradition,
sort of driving on the kind of issues
that come from the earliest period
of empire and of imperialism.
It's also a way in which imperial powers
almost always create
divisions within the countries
that they are in control of.
And culture here is
probably more important
than straightforward politics.
It brings us back to what we talked about
at the beginning of this
lecture in terms of identities,
in terms of discouraging
dissent among the colonized,
because the cultural
power of the colonizer
is so much greater.
For instance, we are
international, we are global,
we are great power, we are super power,
while you are not, right?
You are local.
So culture works in that way, I think,
with regard to imperial projects,
and probably is the
last thing to go, right?
I think it's pretty clear
in the case of Ukraine,
and eminently visible in the
case of Algeria and Ireland.
This is certainly so, and it is an issue.
It's an issue that of course,
only colonized people after decolonization
can deal with themselves successfully.
But it is an important issue.
So I wanted to make sure that
we have a little bit of time
at the end for questions.
So I'm just gonna make some final remarks
first about Russian imperialism
today versus Ukraine.
But then I think more importantly
in terms of what I know something about
how the effects of this
war are going to resonate
on the Russian side in terms
of dealing with the past
including the deeper past.
So I have absolutely no doubt,
as you might have guessed,
in terms of how I framed this lecture,
that Russian imperialism
today versus Ukraine
will end in the same way
as England and Ireland
and France in Algeria in decolonization,
in spite of neo-colonial wars.
So I mean, the Russians in Ukraine in 2022
are not the first ones who
engage in neo-colonial wars.
I mean, Algeria, and in my view Ireland,
are also good examples of it.
You find it in almost
all parts of the world.
This idea that if a formal association
in terms of empire is gone,
that that's the end of the story.
Almost in all imperial context, not so.
This continues to be problematic
for a very long time after that.
And part of the reason for that, I argue,
is that these positions are so closely
bound up in identities,
in core identities,
for many of the people who are involved,
not just on the side of the colonized,
but perhaps even more powerfully
on the side of the colonizers.
And this is what we sometimes
do not understand well enough,
maybe especially in the Russian case,
because this has been
including the collapse
of the Soviet Union, such
a long and outdrawn affair.
This is in many ways
about Russian identity.
And it is, in my view, first and foremost,
identity in Russia in
the sense of an inability
to deal meaningfully with the past.
I spent a lot of time in
Moscow in the early 1990s.
As Wiktor said, I worked on
the history of the Cold War.
There was no better
opportunity for a historian
of the Cold War than to be
in Moscow in the early 1990s
when the archives started to open up
and you could get access.
I also then was witness to
how people almost overnight
went from belonging to one
of the two superpowers,
which gave immense pride to
a lot of people in Russia
over onto being next to nothing.
People starving, people in Moscow,
elderly people starving to death in 1993.
So that sense of collapse, being déclassé,
everything taken away,
is a very important reason I think
why Putin has been able to develop Russia
or not develop Russia in
the direction that he has.
Course also manipulates very effectively,
at least up to the war in Ukraine began,
the image globally of the Soviet era
as a kind of anti-empire,
while in reality,
of course the Soviet
Union kept some, not all,
but some of those visions
of empire relatively intact.
So what Russia needs, in my view,
probably more than anything
else except regime change,
is a reckoning with the past.
Just like there is a
need to discuss slavery
and settler colonialism in Europe
and in the Americas and elsewhere,
there is also a deep need for
Russians to discuss the effect
the empire has had on
those at the receiving end,
but also, and maybe more fundamentally
on Russians themselves,
because it's very
difficult, as this country,
United States is slowly realizing
to be an empire and a republic.
To be an empire, nevermind a democracy,
but even a functioning
republic at the same time.
So these forms of what I
call hybrid exceptionalism
that Vladimir Putin has been using
in his war of aggression against Ukraine,
when Foreign Minister
Lavrov at the beginning
of the conflict spoke about Ukraine
as being a Russian sphere of
privileged interest, right?
You can see how that resonates
with some of these drivers
of Russian imperialism
that I've been talking about today.
So on the Russian side, it is
as important to deal with this
in terms of empire as it is to
deal with it in terms of war.
So that's what I had to say.
And we have time, I think.
Exactly five minutes for questions,
if there were people who wanted to ask.
Please.
- Was there any conflict
between this Russian
sense of authenticity as
an imperial motivation
and the fact that many of
the servants of imperialism
were themselves not Russian?
- I think there are some links.
I mean, one I think is
that it is the imperial
institution in itself
that is unique in a way.
You sort of project it upwards.
You can see some tendencies
to that during the Soviet era
and the post-Soviet era as well,
this idea of inclusive
representation, right?
People have written whole books about this
comparing the late imperial era in Russia
and the Soviet Union, right?
This idea of representing something
that is much bigger than Russia,
much bigger than the
Soviet peoples themselves
that is immensely attractive to others.
Now, for most of the time,
it should be said, with
regard to the Russian empire,
that wasn't so, with some bulk exceptions.
People were incorporated
into the empire by force
and not by choice, right?
But you can still see
how it could work, right?
This idea that you
represent some bigger idea
that is not even necessarily
Russian in nature,
but has the Russian state,
the Russian imperial state
in this case at its center.
Other questions?
Yeah.
- [Student] You hinted that
what you think Russia needs
is regime change and
reckoning with the past.
Do you think that when
regime change does come,
they will bring this
reckoning with the past or no?
- I certainly hope so.
The track record is not particularly good
with regard to this.
Look, there's been, over
the last 20 years in Russia,
I'm sure all of you're aware of that,
a very specific set of
attempts of moving away
from dealing with the past
in any meaningful sense.
I mean, to some extent,
that is what the Putin
regime has been about, right?
A kind of denial of everything
that has happened before.
Not always in a specific sense.
It's very interesting, right?
So as an archival historian,
I found it fascinating
that in the very last
two, three years before
the invasion of Ukraine,
Putin, we know that it was Putin himself,
acted to open up many
archives from the Soviet era.
And we don't know the
reason why that was so.
I have a strong suspicion
that the real reason was
to compare his own regime
favorably with what had been
the failure of the Soviets.
I mean, Putin, as you will know,
his constituent elements is
that he's an anti-communist.
He believes that the communist era,
in spite of the little parenthesis
around the great patriotic war,
that communism was bad for
Russia, bad for Russians.
It might have been good for
other peoples in the empire,
but it was bad for Russians.
So I think you have to have
a pretty significant change,
not just in terms of the regime itself,
which can go in any direction.
I'm not in any way foreseeing
that what comes off
for Russians necessarily
is better than Putin.
But in terms of thinking about the past,
I think it's more significant
in terms of society
than it is significant
in terms of the state.
Of course, the state must
not resist it or disallow it,
but my greatest shock with
regard to the 2014 invasions
and the 2022 invasions was
how many ordinary Russians
who were, at least the step
of the way, carried along.
Boy, this pack of lies and half truths
that Putin presented as the
justification for colonial wars.
And that tells me that
there is a lot of work
among Russians themselves to do,
to understand how they are held back
by this imperial mindset.
Because as I said in the
case of the other examples,
this always ends badly
when you are gotten to the
early part of the 21st century.
One final question, if there is one.
If not, let me make one
very brief point at the end.
So in this lecture,
I've tried to look at
sort of the long delay,
the kind of trajectories
that come out of the past,
even the deeper past.
I've not done so trying to tell you
that history explains everything.
It doesn't.
There are new directions, new trajectories
that are not necessarily
connected to the past.
But if you wanna try to
understand terms, terminologies,
parts of language, ideas and identities,
then history can be a great guide,
because history brings
something to the table
in terms of understanding the present,
which can explain things that otherwise
would be really, really hard to explain.
So that's, in a way, my
message in this lecture.
Doesn't explain everything.
But it's hard to make do without it
because of the things that it
can help you to understand.
All right, thank you very much.
(students applauding)
(soft gentle music)